my name is Ashan shat I a senior
software engineer at Nvidia I'm going to
talk to you about a project we've been
working on called cf. pandas which is a
tool that lets you take pandas code and
run it on the GPU without making any
changes to
it uh to give you an outline for this
talk we'll start by doing some
reflection on pandas and some of the
alternatives to pandas that have come up
over the last couple years uh I'll give
you then a demo of cf. pandas and show
you what it's all about then we'll come
back and talk about how it works some
frequently asked questions and some
limitations and then we'll
conclude the demo that I'm going to use
for this code you can access using the
QR code on the top right uh you can also
find it as the latest updated repost
story on my GitHub my GitHub ID is s h w
i
n uh but we'll come back to that QR code
in a bit okay so I want to want to talk
about pandas and I want to talk about
some of the other kind of alternatives
to pandas pandas is great but it can be
slow on the right you're seeing the
results of the H2O AI benchmarks that
are maintained by Duck DB and it's
measuring the amount of time it takes
different libraries to do a group ey on
a 5 gigabyte data set and you can see
here that pandas appears near the bottom
of this Benchmark in terms of
performance so why is pandas slow it's
for two reasons the first is that panas
is largely single threaded which means
that it can't use more than one CPU core
on your machine and it's not a query
engine like a lot of these uh Frameworks
and libraries are so there have been a
lot of alternative sandas that have come
up that try to address the performance
Gap some of these are written in a
faster underlying language like C++ or
rust some of these are more SQL like
they don't have a panis like API some of
these are query engines others let you
distribute your computation across
computers and some of them are Hardware
accelerated or they can use things like
gpus so I want to talk about CF which is
a GPU based data frame
Library uh it's the project that I work
on uh it's uh a library in Python that
gives you a pandas like API except that
runs on GPU underneath qdf certain using
a combination of Cuda which is nvidia's
programming language for talking to GPU
and C Plus+ and that underlying library
is called lip
CF uh and because lip CF can work with
the GPU uh and because GPS are fast CF
is extremely fast it can be up to 10 to
100 times faster than pandas depending
on the operation you're doing you can
see here on the lower right some of the
speedups we get versus pandas for
different kinds of operations you might
want to do with pandas data frames uh qf
supports about 60 to 75% of the panda
API depending on your definition of the
pandas API and how you measure it so it
doesn't support all of pandas but we're
not going to talk about qdf in this talk
we're going to talk about something else
we're going to talk about how to take
your existing pandas code and not have
to import anything not even CDF and just
be able to run it on gpus we'll talk
about what that gets us um and all the
nice things about
it so just stepping back and asking this
question if I'm a data scientist or I'm
a library developer that uh works on a
library that uses pandas should I switch
from pandas to something else and the
answer is uh maybe there are reasons to
use something other than pandas like
poers or dask or even qf and there's
reasons you may not want to use those
libraries the re some reasons you might
want to switch away from pandas is if
performance matters to you a lot uh if
performance matters to you a lot and you
don't mind rewriting your code for
example then you should switch away from
pandas because there are definitely
faster
Alternatives uh if data size is what's
limiting you if you have terabytes of
data for example then pandas is unwieldy
at this data size so you might want to
use something else but there are reasons
you might want to keep using pandas uh
for example if you like the API
flexibility the pandis gives you then
you'll see that some of these
Alternatives don't really have the same
amount of flexibility in the in their
apis if you're collaborating with people
that use pandas then you may want to
stick to using pandas uh another big
reason to use pandas especially if
you're a library developer for example
um is that pandas is very battle tested
there's a huge ecosystem of libraries
that are built on top of pandas and
we're not going to have an easy time
convincing the maintainers of all those
libraries to switch away from pandas
into something else and then the final
and maybe the most important reason that
you might want to keep using pandas is
that it is getting faster uh there's
been a few talks at F data Global about
some updates uh that have happened to
Panda
or explaining those updates we've seen
some nice speed ups between panas one
and two and we're going to expect to see
some more exciting speed ups between
pandas 2 and three so pandas is getting
faster so I'm now going to talk about
cf. pandas and what we're trying to
achieve with this project cf. pandas is
exploring what it might look like for
everyone to say okay I'm going to keep
using pandas but I also am going to get
the speedups that I can get from using
the GPU so how does this work it lets
you keep using pandas you don't change
anything about your code you still
import pandas in your programs you still
use libraries that use pandas uh but uh
those pandas calls are accelerated on
the GPU and kf. pandas can in this way
support 100% of the pandas API the way
it does that is that certain operations
run on the GPU and other unsupported
operations run using pandas on the the
CPU uh third party code that you might
be using is accelerated no one needs to
change their code uh but everyone gets
to use the GPU without without any
changes how does this look it looks like
what you're seeing on the right here if
you're running on Jupiter you just load
an extension called kf. pandis and now
pandas calls will use a GPU and there's
similar incantations for when you're
using the command line or if you want to
directly import the cf. panders
extension and install it so so at this
point I'm going to switch to a jupter
notebook and I'm actually going to show
you what this looks like uh what the
experien is using cf. pandas there's
really not much to teach here uh cf.
pandas just lets you use pandas like
regular there's no new API to learn uh
but I'm going to show you some kind of
tricks to get better performance and
show you some neat features of cf.
pandas uh you're looking at my Jupiter
setup here which can be a little
intimidating to look at but I'll explain
what's going on we're basically going to
run a single notebook there's two
versions of that Notebook on the left is
the version that we're actually going to
run here and that version of The
Notebook loads the kf. pandas extension
there's a copy of this notebook on the
top right that just uh comments out that
lane which means that when we import
pandas on the left we're going to import
you know qdf pandas version of pandas
and on the top right we're going to keep
using regular pandas I've also given the
kind of pure pandas notebook a head
start here and I've gone ahead and
executed all of the cells just because
it can take some time but the cf. pandas
version we're going to run live and see
see what that looks
like uh and on the bottom right here of
the Jupiter screen you'll just see uh
the the two gpus that I have on my
machine and what's going on with
them okay so let's see what we're doing
in the first part of this notebook I'm
just loading the cf. pandas extension
I'm importing a few python libraries I'm
generating some random data and then I'm
going to apply some very common kind of
pandas operations on that
data if you look at the results that I
got on the CPU you'll see that I timed
those results and we're going to compare
those timings with what we get when we
use the GPU via cf. pandas so for this
groupy operation for example on the CPU
it took about 160 milliseconds on the
GPU takes about 1 of that okay what
about when we do a string operation I'm
looking at a string column and I'm
trying to see if it contains another
substring on the CPU that took about 3
seconds and with the GPU enabled it
takes you know 50
milliseconds okay A a couple more
examples here
um well I ran the wrong code the string
contains is actually 9 milliseconds on
the GPU uh I went ahead and R the second
example which is a merge which on the CP
took 1 second and the GPU was 50
milliseconds and then this last one is
interesting we're doing a count
operation on both the axes of the data
frame and what's interesting about it is
that when we run count the count method
on the Zero axis that is actually quite
fast than the GPU but when we run count
on axis equals one which is along the
rows that's actually slower than the
pandas version the pandas version took a
little over a second and the GPU version
using kf. btis takes closer to two
seconds okay so we saw some impressive
speedups from using the GPU for
relatively simple
operations uh but we also saw one
example of where we didn't get a speed
up so how is this working how are we
actually getting any kind of speed up
from using you know Panda's operations
when we load the qf extens cf. panas
extension well it happens because when
you load the cf. panas extension
and you import pandas or any of its subm
modules what you get back is not the
actual pandas Library you get a proxy
for the Pand library that proxy contains
proxy functions and proxy types and
those types have proxy methods and the
way these proxies work is that whenever
you invoke one of these proxy functions
or methods what actually happens is that
you are
invoking uh a function that's going to
try to execute the qdf GPU version of
that function first and if that fails
for some reason it's going to copy data
from the GPU to CPU and then execute the
pandas or the CPU version of that
function and then we return ourself back
to you but all of this happens behind
the scenes and to you the end user it
really just looks like you're using
pandas and things just magically happen
on the GPU so this kind of explains why
when we run the count method and we
provide axis equals one uh that ran
slower than regular pandas because we
not only had to well that not only fell
back to using pandas on CPU we also have
to pay the additional cost of moving
data between the CPU and the GPU and
that can be significant when you have
large data
sets Okay so moving on when we use this
proxy Library cf. panas can we continue
to use third party libraries like
Seaborn uh the answer is yes I'm
plotting my data remember my data lives
on the GPU at this point I'm plotting
some data in my data frame uh by passing
it to caborn and it just works it just
works because cbor is also importing
pandas but when it does that it's also
importing this kind of proxy version of
pandas and everything just uh work
smoothly uh with each
other okay
so we're moving on now to the second
part of this demo we saw some basics of
cf. pandas how to use it and some of
it's ESS
features but I want to talk more about
this question of performance we saw that
we got some nice speedups from using cf.
pandas but we also saw that there are
situations where your code may not get a
lot of speed up in fact you might even
get slowdowns so I'm going to talk about
what you can do about that to study this
problem we are going to generate some
time series data and we're going to do
some operations on that data
specifically we'll generate the data
then we'll filter it to just the data
that includes uh data for time stamps
between 9:30 a.m. and 4 p.m. and then
we'll do a groupy the resulting filter
data so I'm running this with cf. pandas
on the GPU you'll see some activity here
on the low right uh and you'll see that
this is taking some time it takes some
time even on the CPU I'm showing you on
the CPU it took you know about 11
seconds and we'll see that on the GPU
took 13 seconds so we're not seeing very
impressive numbers here from utilizing
the
GPU so cf. pandis comes with tools for
you to see if you can solve this problem
uh what it comes with is a profiler that
you can enable in the notebook with the
magic cf. pandis profile so I'm just
running the same code with the profiler
enabled and we'll see what that looks
like in just a few
seconds
okay so the code runs like before but
now we also get this report that tells
us every pandis function that was
executed so you can see that these are
the names of different pandis functions
and methods and also it tells us whether
those functions executed on the GPU or
on the CPU and how much time they took
and what you'll notice here is in this
code snippet everything runs on the GPU
except this one function uh indexer
between time so looking back at our code
this one function is what ran on the CPU
you of everything else in the cell r on
the GPU and it can sometimes happen that
when you have bottlenecks like this that
run on the CPU that can slow down your
code in a significant way the key to
getting really good performance with cf.
pandas is to minimize the number of
times this happens you really want to
fall back to using pandas or the CPU
uh as little as possible so one way to
do that is to basically rewrite your
code to use functionality that's
supported by qdf or on the GPU and I'm
doing that here by replacing the call to
index or between time uh using Panda
supported datetime properties so instead
of the called index or between time I'm
using the do hour and the minute U
datetime properties and we'll see that
that gives us the same results but it's
also much faster uh where previously on
the GPU we took you know 14 seconds
we're now taking less than a second
about 700
milliseconds now here's the really cool
thing when you rewrite your code in such
a way that it can execute efficiently on
the GPU it ends up that that code
actually runs faster on the CPU or using
just pure pandas as well on the right
here I've shown you the result of taking
this modified you know GPU optimized
code and I'm running it using the
regular pandas you'll see that we've
brought the the execution time down from
11 seconds to 6 seconds so a nice kind
of 2x speed up so often this is like a
win-win the more efficiently you write
your code for the GPU the more
efficiently it will run using regular
pandas as
well okay and then I'm now going to move
over to the last part of my demo which
is showing how cf. pandas not only
accelerates the code that you write but
it also accelerates the libraries that
you use uh for this example I'm using
Lang chain because it's new and exciting
uh but the point isn't to show off lang
chain or its features or llms or any of
that stuff it's really to show that we
can take this library that was written
to use pandas It Was Written without qdf
or gpus in mind and we can make it
automatically use GPU and that can be to
our benefit we can get some nice
speedups from using those libraries uh
there's a lot of caveat to this uh
setting up this example is kind of
finicky please make sure if you're
trying to reproduce this that you read
the notes that I have here but I'm kind
of going to just gloss over the details
and walk you through what's going on so
at the beginning of this I'm going to uh
import L chain and I'm going to set it
up I'm going to then load some data into
a data frame using the read parket
function uh when I do this you'll see
that my GPU kind of fills up on the
bottom right
Okay so we've loaded our data I've then
kind of filtered out to just the columns
that we're interested in the data set
that we're looking at is the New York
City Taxi data set uh it contains
information about taxi Dives in New York
including like pick up and date times uh
pick up and drop off date times the
company that owned the taxis uh for each
ride how many passengers there were how
much did they tip and whatnot we're then
going to create a lang chain agent which
will help us ask questions about this
data uh and it will answer those
questions by executing pandas code for
us so we don't actually have to write
the pandas code to answer these
questions so the first question I'm
asking is how many rows are there in
this data set uh and you can see that it
answers with there's about 30 million
eurs in this data set I'm asking another
question which is which company received
the most tips out of this data set you
can see that it very quickly answers
that too
the final question that I'm asking uh is
a little bit more complex and it's going
to need pandas to run uh resample
operations and those can be sometimes
slow with pandas so when I ran this uh
example with pure pandas you can see on
the top right this question took uh
about a minute to come back to me with
an answer and we'll see that because
we're using the of that pandas extension
Lang chain will end up using the GPU for
this for this
query uh you can see there's some GPU
activity it completes very quickly and
we get the same answers except we got it
in two seconds instead of a minute so
again the goal here wasn't to show off L
Chain's you know pan dis integration
it's cly to show that a library that was
written without the GP in mind can still
use the GPU because of the way kf.
works uh okay so just to do a recap of
that demo cf. pandas accelerat your code
on gpus with requiring no changes on
your part the key to getting good
performance from kf. pandas is to
minimize the CPU execution and third
party libraries that are written to use
pandis can now use the GPU back via cf.
pandis okay uh let me switch defa
here so how does this work what is
actually going on here uh it works by a
couple of uh kind of tricky bits of
python the first is it works via proxy
pattern we have proxy types and proxy
functions and those proxy types look
something like this we have our own
version of data frame and every method
of data frame for example count works
like this it tries to do the operation
by calling the underlying qdf uh count
method and if that fails it's going to
kind of orchestrate the movement of data
between CPU and GPU and it's going to
run the pandas version of that method
and we have some tricks to kind of
autogenerate these proxy types and proxy
methods for us the second trick is that
we have to customize the way import
Works in Python so when you do import
pandas with the cf. pandas extension
loaded we have to deliver a proxy module
to you we do that by using some of the
kind of more advanced tools provided by
the python standard library and the
import Li module uh to hack the way
Imports
Works does this really work it does um
we test directly against the pandas test
Suite uh and currently cf. pandas passes
94% of the pandas test Suite so that's
the degree of compatibility you can
expect between using kind of regular
pandas and qdf pandas uh but what about
some other approaches or other projects
in this space uh what about duct typing
a lot of existing p like libraries
expect to work with the world using duct
typing but duct typing doesn't always
work uh it doesn't work for free
functions like pd. CSV so you can take
some data frame like object and you can
pass it to some function expecting a
panis data frame and that might work but
what if this function is calling uh you
know free functions like pan pd. concat
for pd. CSV at that point things start
to break the other thing is that there's
a lot of code out there that is
currently doing a hard is instance
checks which means that you can try to
pass in a pandas like object but it will
still fail because a lot of code out
there is saying I'm expecting a panis
data frame by doing an is instance check
so duct typing is great uh but it
doesn't always
work there's also another effort that we
should talk about here which is the data
frame standard API this is uh
maintainers of different data frame
projects coming together in deciding on
a standard API for data frames and that
kind of solves some of the problems but
it's still solving a different problem
than the one we're trying to solve we
are trying to enable the pandas API on
gpus but the data frame standard API is
more a developer focused API so if
you're a library developer then it is
appealing to use the data frame standard
API um in fact we are excited about the
data API we're part of the Consortium we
are working towards developing the
standard with other data frame
maintainers because it's going to unlock
some exciting possibilities like it's
going to enable us to fall back to a
faster data frame liary like poers when
it executes on the
CPU okay so I'm going to end this with
some FAQs the first one is will my code
Run 100 times faster um the answer is
yes if you write your code using
idiomatic pandas or using parts of the
pandas API that are meant to be
efficient for data processing you can
get really good speedups using the GPU
and the profile profiler will help guide
you here it will show you what parts of
your code are running efficiently and
what parts are running on the
CPU uh as a bonus if you optimize your
code for gpus you'll get better CPU
performance uh second question how much
of the panda APA does this support if we
da do support 100% uh just remember that
some operations fall back to the
CPU will qdf panders work with some
arbitrary third party Library um yes but
with some known limitations uh if
there's hard is instance checks for nump
Addis that does work libraries that use
the cap API or subclass p. data frame
are known not to work we're working on
resolving these issues but right now you
can expect some rough
edges uh and finally what about working
with data is larger than GPU memory
again this is a problem that we're
actively thinking about but right now
this will work it will just work by
Falling Back to the
CPU okay so how do you get started uh
again there's a QR code on the screen
for accessing the materials from this
demo uh there's some resources in that
GitHub repository that will point you to
places like the g. pantis docks there's
also a link to try this on Google collab
uh using a free GP instance if you don't
have a GP behind you right now uh with
that thank you and I'll uh see you all
on Discord to answer questions and if we
have some time answer some questions
here fantastic thanks so much asosan
that was phenomenal it looks like we
have a few questions in the chat we got
five minutes so we'll kind of hit as
many as we can um and obviously everyone
in the audience if you have any
lingering or pending questions feel free
to toss them in the Q&A we can get them
answer to you hopefully before taking
this
Discord um let's open up this chat real
quick
quick um so we'll have in
collateral do you want me to go ahead
and pick these and answer something or
I'll let you coordinate sorry no yeah
course I say if we can jump into it so
this first one I see do we get
Improvement in performance only when we
use uh cf. pandas on GPU or are we also
getting performance gain on the CPU as
well um also does it work in cluster
example multi noes
architect okay these are good questions
so kf. pandas really is a GPU
accelerator you if you're on the CPU
you're just using pandas so there's no
speed up and if you have a GPU it's
going to accelerate some functions on
the GPU so it's not going to rewrite any
like CPU code for you so you only get
speed ups with GPU the second part of
the question is can you scale this to
multi noes uh cf. pandas we have some
initial tests to show that it's working
with dask it's going to be something
that we uh spend more resources on um
and scaling scaling it out with dask is
one option although there's there's
going to be a few more options for
scaling out in in the coming
months awesome it looks like um are
there Docker images available otherwise
I imagine this is difficult to install
in environments without cond yep so we
have cond
pip and Docker install
instructions I think the best way to
find them is to get to our GitHub
repository just search for GitHub qdf or
go to
rapids. um and you'll find yourself in
the install page for different Rapids
libraries and you can find instructions
for for all of those uh
platforms awesome looks like there's
some questions around um where to find
this material so again we'll take this
Discord um there is a landing page
within the reception area um within the
air meet where you can kind of go in and
play around with some Discord for
different talks that we've had so far
there's a question is there a problem
with GitHub link or QR
code uh maybe I'm gonna I'm gonna make
sure that this GitHub reposter use
public uh but I will post an update to
to Discord and make sure everyone can
access this awesome so it looks like
it's not working currently um for
applying UDF will you have benefits
using the GPU
yes we actually take user defined
functions and we compile them with
number so if you're operating on kind of
more common data types like numerical
types or date times or even strings
those will actually execute on the GPU
uh there's some limitations here there's
a whole page in the qdf docs that
explains the limitations and
capabilities of user defined
functions phenomenal that's all
everything or that's everything thus far
again we got um about 2 minutes left so
if there's any pending questions feel
free to um drop them in here real quick
again I just want to say quickly thank
you um to all the attendees who chose to
take some time out of their day to
attend this talk um obviously Ashan
thank you so much for uh going in depth
in this presentation and demo I found it
to be super super useful um so like I
said if there's no pending questions
I'll give you guys maybe a few minutes
or a minute to navigate to your next
event um but it looks
like
Dem okay so sorry the issue here was
that this was private and I'm G to make
it public just
now do you want to toss up the QR code
real quick just in case people as their
way on on out the door want to
scan
yep the QR code will take you to the URL
um but I'll also post it on Discord
and it's going to work in just a couple
minutes when I make this public I
apologize for the confusion